le jour de l'indépendance si chère aux
américains tournent au drame ce matin
dans cette banlieue de chicago
ces familles à l'arrière du défilé
réalise ce qui est en train de se
produire
et tentent de fuir le plus rapidement
possible
cet homme croyait que des soldats de la
marine rendait hommage au drapeau
mais quand il a vu tout le monde courir
et s'est enfui comme des milliers de
personnes il a laissé ses effets
personnels derrière lui certains ont
abandonné des poussettes pour le sauver
des balles il a même caché son fils dans
une benne à ordures
j'ai vu au moins trois personnes
ensanglantées au sol raconte cet autre
témoin un moment de réjouissance devient
une opération policière
selon les autorités plus d'une trentaine
de personnes ont été touchées
[Musique]
le présumé tireur un jeune homme de 22
ans originaire de la région a été arrêté
en soirée après une chasse à l'homme qui
aura duré plusieurs heures
il se trouvait sur un toit au moment de
la fusillade une arme très puissante dit
il a été retrouvé sur les lieux
[Musique]
le président byden se félicite d'avoir
fait adopter dit il la première vraie
réforme du contrôle des armes à feu
depuis près de 30 ans mais convient-il
et reste du travail à faire depuis la
fusillade dans une école du val d au
texas à la fin du mois de mai plus de 95
fusillade et de masse dont qui ont fait
plus de quatre blessés ont été recensés
aux états unis faisant plus de 115
victimes
les etats unis sont également secoué par
des manifestations à la suite de la mort
d'un autre jeune homme noir abattu par
la police en noyaux par ces
manifestations aussi contre la décision
de la cour suprême de révoquer le droit
à l'avortement a nommé
une note d'optimisme en ce 4 juillet qui
a bien besoin d'un peu de lumière ici
sébastien desrosiers radio-canada
washington